I've always wanted to shave my head I
have instructions here sent to me by a
barber it's to it no retreat no no
surrender let's get started hello and
congratulations I'm making a bold choice
of Shaving your own head feel like a
Skrillex fan I keep getting scared that
it's gonna like rip my hair out he's
gonna need help from a friend by
following these easy steps you will join
an elite class of people who enjoy a
trouble-free hairstyle that looks sharp
and requires little maintenance this is
all true before we begin this process we
advise you to consider what you're about
to do I feel like I'm getting a call
your hair will grow back eventually but
you should be prepared to have your
appearance dramatically altered please
take a moment to consider this and then
confirm to the camera that you're
confident about your city to continue
I'm confident about my decision the
following brush to toothbrush Sena tech
what do I need to take brush part I
don't have that actually fresh but I
don't know what that's for but we'll
find out it's my boyfriend's gibberish
so you don't have to tell him Aamir's
I'm using cameras for that you can't see
this but I have like a big monitor
that's basically I'm here if you have an
unhealthy air at home by all means use
it you're gonna need it to look at the
back of your head I do not have a
handheld mirror so be sure to check your
scalp for mole scars or skin tags be
especially careful while cutting these
areas I'm a pro okay I never chopped off
anyone's ear or a skin tag or moles
nothing I can remember if I have I block
it out if you are starting with longer
hair you can remove most of length now
to simplify the buzzing process I'm
gonna skip the cutting off of most of it
because I feel like it'll feel better to
just buzz the head immediately I
understand Simon's logic to get that
satisfaction of like all those long
locks coming off and that's really nice
just understand that you may get some
some catching as your clippers are going
through your hair oh my gosh here we go
this is exciting that's happening I
would recommend taking smaller sections
instead of just two pigtails try to
impor that looks like it hurt step one
determine the desired length
determine how long you would like your
hair to be and install the appropriate
attachment the numbers on the
attachments represent the length of hair
that will remain after buzzing in the
following approximate fashion eight
equals one inch
six is 3/4 inch four is 1/2 inch 2 is
1/4 inch start with a larger number and
work your way down from there you can
take more off but you can't put hair
that is the best advice I'm gonna start
longer I want to maintain some length on
top not a ton I'm gonna start at the
longest length that I have which is a 4
which will be a half 1/2 inch which is a
number 6 and that is three quarters of
an inch I'll start with 6 and then I'll
or I'm gonna do that all over first
everywhere and then afterwards when I go
to the sides I'm going to go shorter
step 2 buzz the sides make sure you have
the chosen guard properly installed
before you game and diagonal rather than
parallel to the edges of the Clipper
diagonal parallel starting at your
sideburns Buzz upwards making a sweeping
motion out from the head where the skull
starts to curve be mindful that your
guard does not come off the Clipper
while in use work your way toward the
back and then stop your hair's coming on
OK practicing the sweeping motion up and
away see how dark the side of his head
is still even though he just cut it all
off it's dense hair
maybe that's the sound of the Clippers
catching a little bit that doesn't mean
she's doing anything wrong it just means
that there's a lot of hair there I love
this I could watch people shave their
heads all day long
that's right my god as a professional I
have a little brush that's just for
thinning clippers so my roommate's
toothbrush is safe it's like mowing the
lawn now I'm gonna do the left side I'm
gonna try and improve my technique
this is making me excited to cut my hair
all right here we go
this feels great
I think this is a good look I might stop
here these Clippers are firmly against
my stealth my head is my guide I really
hate it already it was cool so the
sweeping motion when you go like this
and I kind of out a little bit you
following the shape of your head right
there it's just good practice if you
want the sides shorter than the top
because it's gonna help preserve some of
the length and graduation of ladies I'm
gonna get these lots of parts so if
you're going over your head with the
Clippers and you feel like it's not
catching all the hair the best thing to
do is changing the direction of the
Clippers so try going against the grain
of your hair I already feel so much
lighter
step 3 buzz the back and top work your
way from the bottom up and into the
crown I'm pretty sure this is the Krenim
find it that already by accident I don't
think it's wrong the only reason I like
to separate it into different sections
and do the sides first is just to keep
it organized you may need to pause from
time to time to brush your clippers and
keep them cutting well when you are
satisfied with the back move on to the
front if you don't have a mirror you
won't know that you're satisfied by
looking at it so you're gonna have to
rely on touch start with the back and
work my way from the bottom up into the
crown run your clipper or trimmer from
front to back keeping it close to the
scalp to ensure it is cutting smoothly
nobody do that starting in the center of
your head work your way around to match
the size
this is my Britney Spears moment my
shaped head inspirations 11 obviously
from stranger things Natalie Portman V
for Vendetta hello
I love Vincent castle with a buzz cut
Ewan McGregor and trainees vlogging Shia
LaBeouf let's cool with the buzz cut
Keanu Reeves and speed Michael
Fassbender looks really cool with a buzz
cut
pretty much everyone looks really cool
with a buzz cut I can see why people pay
other people to do this doing the back
I'm gonna be tough it's tough for
everyone mirror or no mirror I'm gonna
hold the hair so there's some tension as
well it's right up against there
[Music]
okay that was step three
I've cut the sides the back and the top
now it's all even with the number six
guard let's see its next step 4 check
your work and repeat check to see that
the sides back in front are even feels
good you may need to repeat the above
steps to assure your buzz cut is clean
and even refined if you'd like to go
shorter attach us all our number guard
and work through these steps again I am
looking at myself I think it looks
pretty good so I'm gonna move on to step
5 I really wanted like a shorter cut
still so right now I have a 4 on I'm
gonna take that off and put on a 3 I
would like to go shorter I'm gonna put
at number 4 on ya starting back from the
beginning which is busting the sides
from the sideburns on the side
sweeping she's already not following
directions supposed to start on the
sides she started at the top it's ok
it's not good if you think you want to
go shorter go shorter this is such a
small difference between number 4 and
number 3 for example that if you think
it's going to look better than it
probably will this good a decent job I'm
gonna have to have somebody look at at
some point but for now I think just good
job it's a lot of hair I don't know I
mean like this is cool and everything
but 103 dang she's really going for it I
you know what just go with no guard
I might go shorter still I'm gonna
change out my 3 or
which is a quarter-inch yeah so we
trying to get rid of the part so she
still got that part from her her center
part you can still see it even though
she's coming from her so short she
should cut in the opposite direction of
where it throwing so since it's going
down like that she'll have to go like
that and then like that but then once
she shampoos and it's like brushing
again it'll stick up like the rest of
her hair I mean I actually feel like
this doesn't look too alright that
length I like his hair looks good when
it's cut this thing looks a lot like
Joseph gordon-levitt he officiated with
head in 50/50 and he was great
step 5 size down to refine once you've
completed your buzz cut you can refine
the sides and edges of the best sizing
down I'm gonna keep the difference
slight between the sides on the top and
go from a six to a four I was on to yes
number one I'll try and you two on the
sides this cowlick here I know you guys
can see it
goes down Clippers and I may even need
to size down once more for that I have
no idea how it is hard to say well trust
my life feels he's gonna need help from
a friend I'll try the other one
I like this link better it makes them
more narrow shape on my head before it
was kind of sticking out a little bit
more because I have the parietal Ridge
that sticks out a little bit but this
cheats it this stuff tends to grow
faster than this stuff and so in two
weeks if I keep the sides at the same
length as the top they're gonna look
longer if my head's gonna start looking
like a football instead of up and down
like this it's gonna start looking
hamburger instead of hotdogs I'd rather
look hot dog this is the part that I'm
most nervous about like the back
hairline but I'm going to trust my
instincts
[Music]
she was doing all the right things she
got her little iPad out she can sort of
see not bad though Wow the only thing
that I would say for him because he has
colleagues as I do in the back that grow
up we'd have to go in the opposite
direction of the direction that your
hair is growing you should go down and
set up up back there to get that weird
colic I brought that three up to about
here
following the parietal Ridge I'm gonna
use this as my guide for the number two
so I'm just going to sweep over the
sideburns kind of like what Simon did in
his last step oh yeah
so i'm following my ear at the guy back
here oh god there's a fly in my
apartment you have to burn it down okay
there's a little bit of a bump right
here that I do believe is going to be my
final step finishing touches your
buzzcut is now done clean yourself off
and look in the mirror how does it look
so I've hair like all over my face and
tickling my nose I'm going to clean
myself off really quick and then I'll be
right back I like the way it looks I
feel I feel really clean and I feel now
that I've done it once and then the next
time I won't have to have the directions
prints out in front of me because I'll
know where to start and the sweeping
motions and that the back is the hardest
and if I have someone around that can
help me clean up the back I think I can
get it down to like looking better and
probably a little bit faster too bye
I think he looks pretty good with the
but I'm gonna say he looks better with
the bust head then with his curls
something about him with the bust it's
sexier I think he looks tougher the only
thing that I would have done if I was
him is to go down opposite direction on
that cowlick in the back that's the only
thing otherwise he gets solid 95 out of
100 I was really nervous about this
before once I started going got into the
Britney Spears zone I do think that I
could like tidy up the sides a little
like I might go a little shorter on the
sides and keep it longer on the tongue
like jarhead style but I feel pretty
happy with it so we did a tremendous job
buzzing her head she didn't follow all
the directions but it doesn't matter
it's a buzz cut it's not supposed to
look perfect kind of like Simon she
looks tougher she's sexier with it it
reveals every part of her face there's
nothing to hide behind
and she's got striking bone structure
you might as well see what your head
looks like because I literally didn't
even know before see I'm gonna go take a
shower get all this hair off of me
I feel gross but I feel handsome it's a
weird combination I I don't know what's
happening